can i ask mr chairman
i thought there was a dress code where
you want to have a title
that's not correct
you have to wait a second because
there's a 20 minute 20 second lag
but just tell them we're about to go
live we're about to go
live members apologies for the continued
delay
all right so um okay you need to shut
you to shut your browser down
and go back into zoom because otherwise
you might get feedback
shut it yeah why is it no shut it it
won't stop at all
do you want to close all tabs yet
because once you're live because i've
got all my addendums
oh
it should show us what should do
members apologize again for the uh
slight delay in starting we are now live
streamed um so i'd like to
welcome you all to rochester district
council's remote annual council meeting
of the 9th of july 2020
and a particularly warm welcome to
anybody watching this
via the live stream
i shall now take item one on the agenda
to elect the chairman
of the council for 2020 stroke 2021
municipal
year council of woodson
thank you with the sad passing of our
good friend and colleague
uh councillor terry cutmore i'm sure you
would be one of the first
to say you wish the circumstances were
somewhat different
but nevertheless uh in remembering him
uh i'm sure he would take great pride in
my nomination and proposal
uh that uh you are nominated for the
second year i can think of no finer
person to
take us forward councillor thank you
councilwood councilor you chairman i
will second that
thank you councillor members if that is
agreed
we will confirm that via a roll call of
names
when i call your name can you please
indicate if you wish to want if you wish
to have a recorded vote
if you are voting for or against the
motion
or if you wish to abstain
councillor mrs belton
no recorded vote for
thank you councillor burton
not with us as yet councillor mrs
butcher
paul no recorded vote
council mr carter yeah
four not recorded
thank you councillor dre for not
recorded
councillor fd i recorded voting for
councillor eves
council eves are you with us
no councillor mrs gooding
no recorded vote and four thank you
councillor hazelwood
for a nor recorded vote thank you
council hookway
council hawkway you're muted
because hopefully you're a mute
i'll come back to you councillor hawkway
councillor high
no recorded vote and i abstain
thank you councillor hudson
no recorded vote and i'm four councillor
ionu
no recorded vote for
councillor lucas gill
no recorded vote and i'm voting for
councillor mrs lumley
no recorded vote and four councillor mrs
mason
uh thank you mr chairman uh you called
councillor neves he's been
somehow dropped out he's trying to get
back in
but apparently it's not being let back
in perhaps you could look at that
sorry i am back now okay oh well done
um that's reads what is your vote mrs
council mrs mason
thank you mr chairman um against a
recorded vote
abstain on the motion thank you i'll
come back to councillor eve then
thank you chair um no recorded vote
and abstain thank you uh councillor
hookway are you with us now
assuming still muted council hawkway
mrs mcpherson no recorded
vote and for the motion thank you
chairman thank you
councilman no recorded vote and for the
motion
councillor newport
no recorded vote and i abstain
councillor mrs pavlin
no recall did vote and for thank you
chairman
thanks for mrs rowe thank you chairman
no recorded vote
and four thank you councillor mrs shaw
no recorded vote and for the motion the
answer mr shaw
no recorded vote for the motion
counselor mr smith
no recorded vote and fought the motion
chairman
now suspending no recorded vote for the
motion
council stanley
council stanley
can you hear me mr cows are stan lee
we called you vote and abstain thank you
council
no recorded vote and four
down to the wall no recorded vote and
four
councillor webb no recorded vote and
four
thank you chairman thank you so mrs
weston
no record you vote and for the motion
councillor wilkinson no recorded votes
and for the motion chain
thank you councillor williams
thank you gentlemen no record is open
for the motion
council wilson and chairman
no recorded vote and abstain
councillor wooden a recorded vote and
four
members that has been passed
27-4 none against
and abstain thank you members
i shall now take item all on the agenda
and i shall now read the statutory
declaration
of acceptance and signed the book of
declaration
i robin richard dre having been elected
to the office of chairman of the council
of the district of rochford
declare that i take that office upon
myself and will julian
faithfully fulfill the duties of it
according to the best of my
judgment and ability on the take to
observe the code
as to the conduct which is expected of
members of rochford
district council i shall now
sign the declaration
three on the agenda uh to elect the vice
chairman of the council for the 2020
stroke 21
municipal year council wooden
thank you chairman uh may just before i
do that might be the first to
congratulate you on
your chairmanship for the forthcoming
year and but
again it gives me pleasure to make a
proposal
that councillor mrs carol weston uh
is the vice chairman for the next
municipal year thank you very much
councilman thank you chairman
and yes congratulations to you thank you
i will second that motion
thank you if that's agreed members we
will take a vote again by roll call of
names
and again when i call your name can you
please indicate as you wished
to have a recorded vote or if you voting
for
or against the motion or if you wish to
abstain
councilman no recorded vote for the
motion
answer burton still not with us
no councillor mrs butcher
no recorded vote and for the motion
thank you
councillor mr carter
yeah no recorded vote and for a motion
thank you
councillor dre myself for the motion
and no recorded vote counselor fd
no recorded votes and for the motion
thank you chairman
councillor neebs
no recorded vote for the motion thank
you counselor mrs gooding
a recorded vote and for the motion thank
you chair
thank you councillor hazelwood
no recorded vote and for the motion
thank you
councillor hawkway
council hook why you're on mute
we didn't hear that uh council could you
repeat that please
and you're muted
against the recorded vote and abstain on
the motion
thank you councillor mr hudson no
recorded vote and for the motion
thank you councillor ionu
no recorded vote and four thank you
councillor mr lucas gill
no to a recorded vote n4 thank you
account for mrs lumley
no recorded vote and four thank you
councilman mrs mason
technology is playing up tonight uh
chairman so i apologize for the delay
um against the recorded vote for the
motion
thank you council mrs mcpherson
thank you chairman a no recorded vote
and for the motion thank you counselor
mr merrick
recorded vote and for the motion
no recorded vote and for the motion
announced the newport
no recorded vote and i abstain
counsel mrs pavlin
so i'm for the motion thank you
counselor mrs shaw
no recorded vote and for the motion
thank you chair
mr sure no recording vote and for the
motion
council mrs rowell thank you chairman no
recorded votes and for the motion
councilor mr smith no recorded vote
and for the motion counselor sparing
no recorded vote for the motion the
answer stanley
and recorded vote and abstain
council a recorded vote
for council award
no and for chairman thank you council
player
a recorded vote and for the motion thank
you chairman
councillor mrs weston no no
no recorded vote and for the motion
chairman counselor wilkinson
no record advice and for the emotional
chat thank you council williams
thank you chairman no recorded voting
for the motion
council wilson no recorded vote and
abstain
councillor wooten a recorded vote
and for the motion thank you members
that has been agreed
i'm sorry my apologies before that um
can i go back to councillor hookway
please we didn't quite hear you
if you can repeat whether you wish to
your your vote
and whether you wish to have a recorded
vote please council hawkway can you hear
me
sorry councilwood way we we cannot hear
you at all
i shall proceed accordingly and
that members has been agreed
29 votes for none against and
four abstentions thank you
and the counselor uh western can i be
first to congratulate you
i've been invited my vice chairman i
look forward to working with you
thank you very much chairman
i would like to thank members here for
electing me as vice chair of watchful
district council
it is an honor and a privilege to occupy
this position from the former vice chair
the late terry cutmore
who sadly passed away in march i have
not been vice chair before but i
realized i will have some very large
shoes
to fill
thank you the declaration to read yes
well bear with me council western will
now take item
four on the agenda the elected vice
chairman of the council
to make the statutory declaration
please continue council western thank
you chairman
aye mrs carol ann weston having been
elected to the office of vice chairman
of the council of watch of dish of the
council of the district of rochefort
declare that i take that office upon
myself
and will duly and faithfully fulfill the
duties
of it according to the best of my
judgment and ability
i undertake to observe the code as to
the conduct
which is expected of members of rochford
district council
thank you chairman thank you council
western for members information
councillor western
will sign the declaration of acceptance
of office when
uh next possible
thank you members i shall now take item
five on the agenda the chairman of the
council to appoint a chaplain
i'm pleased to announce members that
reverend david
oxtoby uh my chaplain last year's agreed
to continue
to be my chaplain for the 2020 stroke
21 municipal year
item six on the agenda to receive
apologies
of absence we have seen apologies
members from council mrs hoy
councillor canal and councillor mrs
carter thank you members
members i shall now take item seven on
the agenda the minutes
of the meetings held on the 18th of
february
2020 and the 19th of may 2020
can i ask members to approve the minutes
of the meeting held on the 18th of
february as a correct
record of the meeting subject to
amending the final sentence on page 29
to read as follows the outstanding two
motions on notice
would be deferred to the next meeting of
council
and also members on this item to approve
the minutes of the meeting held
on the 19th of may 2020
as a correct record
once again members we shall do so by a
roll call of names
again when i call your name can i ask
you please indicate if you want to
recorded vote
if you or if you are voting for or
against
approving the minutes subject to the
change
to the change of the minutes of the 18th
of february as i've outlined
or should you wish to abstain
right counselor mrs belton
no recorded vote for the approval thank
you
no counselor burton councillor butcher
no no recorded vote and i approve
councillor carter mr carter yeah no
recorded vote and
40 approved myself counselor dre
for the motion and no recorded vote
counselor efti
now recorded voting for the motion thank
you councillor eves
no recorded vote and for the motion
councilor mrs gooding
no recorded vote and for the motion
chairman thank you
councillor hazelwood your recorded vote
and four
thank you councillor
a mute councilwood way
you'll come back you can't hear me i'll
come back to you
answer mr hoy no to recorded
vote for the motion or approval thank
you councillor hudson
no recorded vote and for the motion
council no recorded vote
and for the motion thank you councillor
gale no recorded vote and for the motion
thank you councillor mrs lumley
no and four thank you councillor mrs
mason
uh mr chairman if i make a phone
councillor hookway he can't hear you
and the connection is so poor he's going
to dial in so perhaps you can
make sure that someone answers his call
no recorded vote and for the motion
thank you
councillor michigan mcpherson
thank you chairman and now for the
recorded vote and approval
thank you councillor merrick no
and four thank you councilman
no recorded vote and fought a motion
thank you council newport
no and four thank you councillor mrs
pavling
thank you chairman no and approve thank
you
councillor mrs shaw no for recording
vote and approve thank you
councillor mr shaw no recorded vote and
for the motion thank you
councillor smith no recorded vote and
for the motion
thank you council sparing no recording
vote for the motion
now sir stanley no
n4 thank you thank you council steptoe
no and four thank you council ward
known for chairman councillor webb
no and for the motion thank you council
mrs weston
unknown for chairman thank you council
wilkinson
no and approved jim thank you councillor
williams
uh thank you chairman no for the uh
for the approval thank you councillor
wilson
no and full chairman council button
no and approve
thank you membership
we're still waiting for councillor
hawkway uh to dial in
but that members has been agreed so
thank you
members i shall now take item eight on
the agenda
these are the announcements from the
chairman and or head of
paid service there are no announcements
from the managing director
but members i'd like to take this
opportunity of thanking you
for electing me as a chairman of
the current municipal year it's a great
honor
to represent uh rockford district
council
and the residents of rochford uh
and i hope that obviously uh time and
circumstances
will allow us to have uh many more
events
uh that we did then we did last year um
obviously i had a truncated year uh last
year particularly in respect of
um uh the my activities in respect of
the
charities um i had to cancel two
charitable events which was very
frustrating
um but i hope obviously to hold more uh
this year
my charities for this year will be the
same as last year
which are namely the rnli and the
alzheimer's society
mr chairman you are mute
thank you members will now take item
nine on the agenda to elect the leader
of the council for a four year period
or until their term of office ends with
effect from
the 2020-21 municipal year
councillor mrs shaw
thank you chair i'd like to propose
counselor simon woodson
thank you councillor mrs mcpherson emma
may i second that
thank you
sorry mr chairman on a point of order
can i ask how the um
vacancy for leader occurred please
he wanted my id and stuff like that i
don't know what it is
oh
mr chairman you're muted again
there's some feedback from council hook
they just explained to them okay
council hawkway can you hear me now
councillor mr hoyk
sorry chapman you're muted again
sorry i'll get used to it one day
counselor mr
hoy could i ask you please to repeat
your question
yes thank you chairman um leaders of the
council were elected for four-year
terms so normally this would not um we
wouldn't normally be
electing a leader now because they've
only just over a year into their first
term can i ask how this
um vacancy occurred please
uh counselor mr hoy i understand that
council steptoe
resigned from the role and therefore
a new leader was elected by the
conservative group
thank you thank you chairman
councillor mrs mason
you wish to speak yes i'm not sure what
the problem is but
councillor hookway is having exceedingly
great difficulties in contacting you
he can hear you but you're not able to
hear him
although i did hear what he said when he
was voting and
though he is distorted but he's dialed
in
and apparently it's asking for
information that hasn't been provided to
him by the council
i don't know if one of the officers can
phone him and sort this out
because he's being denied participation
in what is
an important meeting
chairman would that not be the password
that we were all sent
um members councillor hawkway has been
like all members been provided with the
details of
how to obtain an access to this meeting
um via virtual meeting or
by telephone we will continue our
efforts to contact him
in the meantime the meeting will
continue
right members you've all heard the uh
proposal and seconder
um if you are happy to approve the
motion
i will confirm that again by a roll call
of names
and when i call your name can i please
could you please indicate as to whether
you require a recorded vote
or wish whether you're wishing which you
wish to vote for
against or abstain from the motion
councillor mrs belton
no recorded vote for the motion
no counselor burton councillor butcher
no recorded vote and for the motion
thank you chairman
councillor mr carter no recorded vote
for the motion myself counselor dre fold
no recorded vote and for the motion
councillor efti
no recorded voting for the motion thank
you councillor eves
i recorded vote abstain thank you
councillor mrs gooding
no recorded vote and for the motion
thank you chairman
thank you councillor hazelwood
no one for thank you council hawkway
can you hear me
we'll move on for that one councillor mr
hoyer
no recorded vote abstain can i have my
vote recorded as such please
you can councillor hudson
council hudson no recorded vote
and for the motion thank you councillor
ionu
no recorded vote for thank you
councillor lucas gill no and
for you councillor mrs lumley
no and four thank you councillor mrs
mason
no recorded vote i'm voting against the
motion and i'd like
that noted thank you thank you
councillor mrs mcpherson
how's the mrs mcpherson
can you hear me now chairman yes luckily
uh no no recorded vote and for the
motion thank you
nelson eric no and four
councilmen no and four
no and abstain could you record my vote
in the minutes please
well councillor pavlin
thank you councillor mrs rowe
thank you chairman no and for councillor
mr shaw
mrs shaw apologies
council smith no recorded vote and for
the motion
the accounts are sparing no recorded
vote for the motion
answer stanley
no and abstain and could i have it noted
please
thank you counselor steptoe
go and abstain council award
no four q councillor webb
no and four count mrs weston
uh known for chairman councillor
wilkinson
no recorded voting for the motion
channel thank you council williams
thank you chairman no and for thank you
council wilson
thank you chairman no and abstain
thank you members
councillor hookway can you hear me now
no no no no counselor
evan you missed councillor woodson my
apologies council watson
sorry i recorded voting for
chairman sorry apologist councillor
woodson
right members that has been
passed 26 votes for
one against and six abstain
thank you members
councillor woodson
thank you very much indeed and thank you
members for your support
um it is an honor and privilege to be
the new leader of rochford district
council
you have my assurance that i will give
the role my full commitment
and i and my administration will do our
very best in the interests of residents
businesses and those who visit the
district
thank you to councillor mike steptoe our
previous leader
who has given dedication and commitment
to the position
and on behalf of the council and i
express our appreciation
for what you have done after several
months
of this dreadful pandemic it would be
quite wrong
not to take this opportunity to
acknowledge and thank
officers and our service provider
partners
for the fantastic way in which they have
maintained
businesses as you business as usual
and good council services
weekly household waste collection
services have continued
uninterrupted open spaces maintained
that are collected as well as the myriad
of other support services
which the council provides on a daily
basis
additionally in conjunction with other
community partners
a community hub was launched in fast
time
and we were overwhelmed with volunteers
anxious to assist
and support vulnerable residents in so
many ways
in the past month or two 18
million pounds has been distributed by
the district
in government funded grants to around
around 1 700 businesses
as lockdown has eased in recent weeks
much work has gone into the we're back
campaign
to safely welcome people back to our
town areas
this all while the council has itself
had to quickly adapt and adjust to new
ways of working
i'm so proud to be the leader of a
district council
which not only met but exceeded
expectations in so many ways
thank you so what do i see in the
immediate
short term in the first instance
i wish to set a time frame of the first
100 days
during that time i will be talking to
officers and listening to their views
whilst at the same time talking and
listening to portfolio holders and
members
the purpose would be to identify those
areas
where there is potential so that we can
set our vision
and create a plan for the future
particularly i would like to see how we
might improve
our engagement with younger people in
this district
so that they are more integrated with
shaping their future
and i look forward to receiving ideas on
how this might be achieved
as we move out of this pandemic there
will undoubtedly be challenges
however alongside these there will be
great opportunities
moving forward the plan will be to
unleash further potential
in order to benefit the communities we
serve
as a relatively small local authority we
can be immensely proud of our
achievements to date
we must however never forget that
irrespective of political differences
as councillors we were all elected to
serve residents
local businesses and continue to make
this place
is this a place we can with
justification
be rightly proud of thank you chairman
muted chairman
thank you for that can i as chairman be
the first to congratulate you
on your appointment councillor steptoe
thank you chairman firstly can i
congratulate you
on your reappointment and councillor
weston
on her appointment as vice chair thank
you
take this the wrong way but it is such a
shame that we don't see terry in the
chair
indeed i would like to thank my team
and portfolio holders for they have
their help over the last 14 months or so
i am of course disappointed i am not
continuing as leader
who would have thought back in january
february
to the challenges that we were about to
face
in fact i recall a meeting with
councillor mike webb
where we discussed the setting up of the
hub
i could see the blood drain from his
face
as we spoke and i'm sure that
you would all agree the council of webb
took on that challenge
and with the help of many from across
the chamber
and from outside organizations
it was a fantastic success very much
it will continue under brad's and the
mega center's
control
the other challenges the council
suddenly found it had to face
was to give away 18 million pound or so
we had spent the last 50 years
collecting money in
so it was something a little strange
the whole of the council stood up to the
challenge
to keep the council working and dealing
with all the normal
things the council has to do
and deal with all the
information that was coming out from
central government and the challenges
that
that presented
i would like to personally thank a few
of the officers
and i'm sure that other members will
agree with me
that out of them
without them we would have been very
lacking
firstly i'd like to thank dawn tribe and
her team
in making it possible for the staff and
members
to work safely from home by putting the
connect program
into fast forward keeping us
all in contact by as soon as we are
tonight
and teams etc
looking into the future it is in my
opinion
that a lot of our meetings will be held
by zoom and teams
and perhaps a combination of virtual
and action
how wood white had his challenges
particularly with
fusion and making sure our assets were
kept safe
louisa morse and her team
i'd like to thank louisa moss and her
team for the work
with the hub and setting up the phone
lines
and making sure that we had that there
was help
was where help was needed it was
delivered
and making sure that had that help was
the correct help
and of course all of those people that
sat on the end of the phone line
um taking the actual course
marcus hotten and the environmental team
making sure that we were all our bids
were rented
i believe there was something in the
increase of 30
in the waste that we collected and can
you imagine
all of those garages and attics are now
nice and clear
making sure that our parks kept working
and the increase in rubbish indicated
how popular our parts were
where we went from collecting emptying
the bins in the parks
on an average on twice a week we were
doing them twice a day
and that continues
only naomi locus and her team suddenly
found
the government government cash
government centers cash
that we had to give away some 18 million
pounds
to local village disease we had to find
a way
to do that very in very short space of
time
and making sure that we didn't go
bankrupt
and delay giving as much help
as the information came from government
it changed hour by hour
i would also like to thank sonya
and her team for dealing with no end of
members issues
i'm not quite sure when sonya went to
sleep
because she was answering emails very
late at night
and of course sean angela hutchins and
angela
for dealing with all of the
communications that government sent
out hour by hour
we heard the headlines but they had to
deal with the small print
which in a lot of cases changed by hour
by hour
as i've already said and then back again
overnight
i'm sure that members would agree that
if we had
to choose an officer of the year
i for one would not know who to choose
we have seen we have some fantastic
officers
who where the chips were down they stood
up
to deal with what was
a very big challenge
chairman i would like
to thank you for allowing me to speak
and say thank you to all of the members
i would however like to finish with a
word of caution for the incoming
administration
to make sure that you look after the the
officers
and the staff you will have to go far
to find better
and i hope that they find a way to deal
with the bullying interference and
control
from people
who should know better i will seek to
influence
in influence matters
chairman thank you for that time
i have enjoyed my time as leader and
previously as deputy leader
i have enjoyed it and i thank thank the
members
for their support thank you thank you
councillor steptoe
council stephano can i add my own thanks
to you personally for
the diligent work and assistance
that you've given us all as a leader of
the council
over the past years thank you very much
councillor mrs mason
uh thank you mr chairman um
i don't really know where to start
firstly
i would like to acknowledge the hard
work that council steptoe has carried
out since his appointment as leader
council steptoe was first elected in
2008
12 years ago and has had held various
portfolios
and i'm sure that his experience will be
missed
that said i agree with the sentiments
already expressed regarding the late
council of terry cutmore
and again his presence and experience
is sorely missed
i trust that the new leader will try to
work
in a constructive way with the minority
groups
and in an inclusive manner we have had
over the past few months of the pandemic
weekly or three weekly calls the group
leaders the minority group leaders with
uh council steptoe during the panel
degree and they have been very
constructive
so i would like to take this opportunity
to thank him for that
thank you thank you this is mason
councillor mrs mason councillor mr hoyer
thank you james so i'm trying to turn my
video on so you can actually see me for
a change
um i'd firstly like to start by paying
tribute to um
um councillor cutmore as well
i will come back to councilcutter in a
minute about something else but i think
again his um knowledge expertise
and just longevity within the council is
very much missed at the moment
um i'm very sorry to see councillor
steptoe
leave as leader of the council um
when he became leader a year ago or just
over a year ago he did say that he would
want to include lead an inclusive
council including members of the operas
opposition groups and i have had
conversations with him around that
and i must say over the last sort of
three months he has held
that up to quite well he's including
group
leaders calls um starting off three
times a week and now down to once a week
at the moment they have been stopped
which is quite a pity but he
but he has been a very good leader
during this time i feel
um i i would
i just have some concerns over the
remarks he made and i'll come back to
that
probably privately to the um chairman of
the council but i think if we have a
a leader talking about bullying
interference and control
i think that does need to be
investigated and i think i will
approach the major director secretary on
that matter um with regard to
um council button i congratulate you on
your new role as
leader i would hope you um are as
inclusive
as um councillor steptoe wanted to be
i would just go back because we're often
accused of not
not being um not participating in the
opposition group so i'll just
remind you that um back in 2011 i did
have a conversation with councillor cut
more
and to his credit he did allow me to to
go onto the rocket hunt
on the rockford housing association as
an opposition member which was quite
unusual
so you have been inclusive in the past
we are willing to be
inclusive with you if you just let us i
just hope your
vision does allow that thank you
thank you thank you council ahoy
councillor newport
thank you chairman um i would just um
on behalf of the liberal democrats i
would like to echo the comments that
um counselor mrs mason and councillor mr
hoy have made
and i would thank um councillor steptoe
um i've recently been meeting with him
with with other minority group leaders
and i've
um i've actually enjoyed uh meeting with
councillor septo
and i found him to um as councillor
mr hoy has uh mentioned
you know to be inclusive of the minority
groups and i actually felt we were
actually
moving forward in a positive way and i
really would welcome
the same dialogue with councillor
wootton
and i congratulate him on his
appointment
thank you very much thank you the
newport
members i shall now take um agenda item
10 and notice of group membership
members to note the details of the group
membership of the council
are set out in item 10 and that will be
confirmed
again by a roll call of names and again
when i call your name
can you please indicate if you wish to
uh wish to have a
recorded vote uh if you wish if you're
voting for or against the motion
or you wish to abstain starting again
with councillor belton
no recorded vote for the motion
council merton no counter burton
councillor mrs butcher
no recorded vote and for the motion
thank you
councillor mr carter no recorded vote
and fought a motion
counselor dre no recorded vote for the
motion
councillor efti no recording vote for
the motion thank you
councillor eves a recorded vote for the
motion
councilor mrs gooding
no recorded vote and for the for the
motion thank you chairman
councillor hazelwood
no one for a council hook why i
understand you've been readmitted can
you hear us please
thank you thank you thank you
councillor mr hoye
uh thank you chairman i can't see any
motions written on the paperwork but i'm
happy to um say no recording vote and
i'm
happy to note the um group membership
thank you
thank you councillor hudson no record
you vote
and indeed i know to the group
membership
council i counselor ionu i record a vote
and i'll
note the membership thank you councillor
mr lucas gill no and four
thank you councillor mrs lumley
no and noted thank you
councillor mrs mason
mr chairman i can't even say no to
recorded vote because there's nothing to
vote on um i note it and accept the uh
papers thank you point taken uh
councillor mason
councillor mrs mcpherson noted
thank you chairman councillor
chairman councillor pavlin
thank you thank you councilman
thank you chairman noted thank you
councillor mrs shaw
noted councillor mr shaw
noted council smith now
and noted gauss's sparing no and noted
council stanley noted thank you chairman
council steptoe owen noted
council ward no noted
councillor webb no and noted
councillor weston no and noted chairman
elsa wilkinson
wilson noted thank you chairman
and councillor wootton noah noted
thank you council woodson members that
has been agreed and noted
thank you members we should now take
item 11
on the agenda this is the appointment of
the executive and committees
2020 to 2021.
councillor wootton could i please ask
you to provide
the council with details of your
appointments to the executive
thank you chairman um i am delighted to
appoint councillor cheryl rowe
as the deputy leader also
the portfolio holder for finance will be
councillor simon smith
portfolio holder for planning councillor
ian ward
councillor councillor arthur williams
will take the
environment portfolio for community
councillor mike webb and for it
and communications councillor daniel fd
in respect of the enterprise portfolio
no appointment will be made
at present in line with what i said
earlier
this will form part of a review and
opportunity will be taken to look at the
alignment of responsibilities
with the directorates in the short term
i will continue to look after the asset
strategy
economic development and employment will
be looked after by my colleague
councillor ian ward and car parking and
tourism
will switch to councillor daniel fd
pending further announcements in due
course
chairman you're mute again sorry
sorry councillors um again i shall ask
members to note the leaders appointees
to the executive
and again i shall do that by a roll call
of names and when i call your names
please indicate if you
wish to vote or against promotion
or simply sorry simply to note the
appointees
counselor belton noted
councillor mrs butcher
noted chairman thank you here council
councillor mr carter
noted chairman thank you myself
counselor dre noted
counselor efti no to chairman thank you
councillor eves noted thank you
thank you counselor gooding noted thank
you chairman
the answer hazelwood
can you hear me council hawkway
noted thank you councillor mr hoyer
noted councillor hudson noted
councillor ionu noted councillor mr
lucas gill
no dude counter mrs lumley
noted councillor mrs mason
chairman that was the mrs macpherson
that's the newport noted
counselor mrs pavlin
chairman thank you councillor mrs rowe
thank you chairman noted counselor mrs
shaw
thank you chairman noted counselor mrs
mr shaw
noted chairman council smith noted
now sparing noted that's a stanley
noted thank you cancer steptoe
noted council ward noted chairman
councillor webb noted thank you chairman
thanks for mrs weston
noted chairman professor wilkinson noted
jim
thank you council williams thank you
chairman
counselor wilson ot chairman
and councilor wooten noted
thank you members that has been noted
um i shall now hand over to um
council mrs law miss law my apologies
miss angela law
to continue with i agenda item 11.
chairman the political composition of
the council should be reflected in the
allocation of seats on the council's
committees
appendix one to the report sets out set
out at pages
11.6 to 11.9
shows seat allocations based on the
current composition in accordance with
the pro writer rules
it also sets out the terms of reference
to all committees
council is therefore asked to endorse
appendix one thank you chairman
thank you angela law members again
um if i will uh confirm approval of that
members
by a row called roll call of names and
when i call your name can you please
indicate
if you want a recorded vote
before i proceed on that basis uh
council will concern you mr speak
mr chairman yes so just for
clarification um
i'm trying to understand from the agenda
whether or not i'm
trying to speak at the right point here
are we talking simply about the
membership are we talking about
chairmanships as well with this
particular item
it's a separate one for chairmanship uh
councilwoman
and then i'll speak at that thank you
okay members as i
i can continue i shall say again um
i'm seeking approval of that members and
by a roll call of names when i call your
names please indicate
your wish to whether if you want a
recorded vote
voting for or against or abstaining
counsellor mrs bert mrs belton sorry
no recorded vote for
councillor mrs butcher
no recorded vote and a great year four
thank you councillor mr carter
no recording voting for councillor
myself
no recorded vote and four
ft no recording vote and four councillor
eves
no recorded voting for now mrs gooding
no recorded vote and four thank you
chairman
thank you council hazelwood
no recorded vote and for the motion
thank you counselor hudson
no recorded vote and four councillor
ionu
no recorded a vote and four thank you
councillor
caspille no recorded vote
and four councillor mrs lumley
no and four councillor mrs mason
no and for thank you chairman
councillor mrs mcpherson no and for
chairman thank you now it's the merrick
no i'm four councillor meown
no and four councillor newport
no and for thank you councillor mrs
pavling
no i'm four thank you chairman mrs
rowe thank you chairman no and for
thank you councillor mrs shaw no and for
councillor mr shaw no and four
council smith no and four
houses no and four thank you council
stanley
no and four thank you council steptoe
oh and four thank you council ward no
and fortune thank you council webb
no and four thank you chairman council
mrs weston
no i'm four chairman councillor
wilkinson
9-4 chairman councillor williams
oh and for approval thank you chairman
you counselor wilson
no and full councilor wootton
no and four
members that has been agreed thank you
i'll pass you back
to angela law chairman appendix 3 to the
report sets out
set out at page 11.13 details
of the minor changes are required to
page 3.22 of the council's constitution
that aligned with the committee set out
in appendix 1.
changes required relate to the addition
of the statutory officer personnel
committee and the income person's panel
penalty council is asked to approve
appendix 3 thank you
german you're muted
members again i shall ask for approval
pro
approval via a roll call and again when
i call your name
could you please indicate if you want a
recorded vote or if you're voted for or
against
or endorsing the necessity of against
endorsement the necessary changes to the
constitution are set out at appendix
3. councillor mrs belton
no recorded vote and 4. thank you
councillor mrs butcher no
and four thank you chairman thank you
councillor mr
carter no recording voting for
thank you chairman myself council adreno
recorded vote
and four no recorded vote
and four councillor eves i recorded
voting for
thank you council mrs gooding
no recorded vote and four thank you
councillor hazelwood
no i'm poor thank you councillor hookway
you know the hook way can you hear us
i record a vote and four
councillor mr lucas gill no
and four councillor mrs lumley
no and four councillor mrs mason
no recording voting for mr chairman
thank you
councillor mrs mcpherson thank you
chairman
uh no recording to vote and four and
this is appendix
um uh three isn't it
it is yes i just wanted about two
sorry chairman did i say appendix two
no not yet
it was i meant to say appendix three
is that clear to everybody yes
councilman merrick
no and four councillor mild
no and four journalists are newport
no and for councillor mrs pavlin
no no i'm four
thank you chairman no and for thank you
council mrs shaw
thank you chair no and for councillor mr
shaw
now and for councillor smith
no recorded vote and four thank you
council sparing
no and four council stanley
no and four thank you council steptoe
now and for council ward
known for chairman councillor webb thank
you
no and for councillor mrs weston
no recording vote chairman and for
council wilkinson
9 4chan thank you council williams
no and four thank you chairman thank you
council wilson
no and for chairman councillor woodson
no i'm four
that members has been agreed thank you
very much i shall now pass you once
again back
to angela law thank you chairman
the group leaders have been invited to
nominate to the council's committees
item 11 addendum 1 commencing on page
11.14 and running to
page 11.18 sets out the membership of
the committees as they would be
taking on board the nominations that
have been received care members please
agree to endorse the nomination set out
in addendum 1 on pages 11.14
to 11.18 thank you
members i shall ask you if that is
agreed and that will be confirmed again
by a roll call of names and again your
name can you
indicate if you wish to recorded vote or
if you're voting for or against
endorsing the membership of committees
as a set out in addendum
one council mrs belton
no recorded vote and four
also mrs butcher no recorded
vote and four thanks chairman thank you
councillor mr carter
no recorded vote and four thank you jim
myself council adreno recorded vote and
four
councillor fd harvey courtney vote and
four thank you chairman
thank you council eves uh no recorded
vote and four
thank you councillor mr mrs gooding
sorry
no recorded vote and four chairman thank
you
counselor hazelwood
no one for thank you council hookway
no to a recorded vote and for the motion
thank you councillor hudson no recorded
vote
and for the motion thank you councillor
ionu no recorded vote and four
councillor mr lucas gill
no recorded vote and four
thank you councillor mrs mason
councilman mrs mason yes sorry mr joe
i've just got a slight question i
believe the officer said
um to page 16. i've got page 18
but i've got no problem with it anyway
so no recorded vote and
four
mcpherson very recorded vote and four
thank you chairman
you counselor mr merrick no
and four councillor meal
no recorded vote and four council
newport
no and four please councillor mrs pavlin
councillor mrs rowe thank you chairman
no
and for councillor mrs shaw thank you mr
chairman known for councillor mr shaw
known for thank you council smith
no recorded vote and four council
thank you council ward no
and for chairman thank you council webb
no and four thank you chairman thank you
council mrs weston no recorded vote
chairman for councillor wilkinson
9-4 chairman thank you council williams
no recorded votes and four thank you
chairman councillor wilson
no and full thank you council wooden
no recorded vote unfortunate thank you
thank you members that's been agreed
thank you very much
i shall now pass you again over to
angela law
thank you chairman nominations have been
received from group leaders for chairman
and vice chairman of the committees
these have been set out in addendum 2 at
page 11.19 and
can be endorsed subject to dealing with
two nominations that have been received
for the chairman of the licensing
and affordability two nominations for
the review committee and two nominations
for the vice chairman of standards
committee
chairman those nominations are all
determined by a roll call of names
so for the chairman of the licensing and
appeals committee members are asked to
indicate if they want to vote for
council mrs gooding or councillor
wilkinson
members again i shall call out a roll
call of names if you could
indicate your wish to vote for either
councillor mrs gooding or council
wilkinson
councillor belton
gooding thank you councillor mrs butcher
councillor mrs butcher
i'll come back to you councillor mrs
butcher councilman
carter councillor mrs gooding
thank you okay myself councillor dre
i'll vote for councillor mrs gooding
councillor fd
council and mrs gooding thank you
councillor mr
eves hello wilkinson
councillor mrs gooding council and mrs
goodin
thank you councillor hazelwood
this is good thank you
councillor hawkway
i'll come back to you councillor hookway
councillor mr hoyer
councillor wilkinson thank you
councillor hudson
councillor gooding thank you councillor
councillor ionu
i'll come back to you council oh yeah
ansel wilkinson
okay thank you councillor lucas gill
council and mrs gooding thank you
councillor mrs lumley
angela mrs gooding councillor mrs mason
council wilkinson thank you councillor
mrs mcpherson
councillor julie gooding thank you
councillor merrick
councilman mrs gooding thank you
councillor milne
councillor mrs gooding council newport
councillor mike wilkinson councilman mrs
pavling
councillor mrs goodman thank you
councillor mrs rowe
thank you chairman uh councillor mrs
goodin and can i just remind you
chairman that councillor mike wilkinson
wishes to speak after
okay thank you so mrs shaw
councillor julie gooding councillor mr
shaw
council mrs gooding thank you councillor
smith councillor mrs gooding
council sparing council mrs gooding
council stanley
council senator wilkinson thank you
council absolute julie gooding
thank you council ward councillor mrs
gooding
thank you counselor counselor mrs
gooding
thank you councilman mrs weston
that's mrs goodin councillor mr
wilkinson
uh myself councilman mr mike wilkinson
thank you
council williams councillor julie
gooding thank you
chairman wilson councillor mike
wilkinson
thank you i'll come back to mr
councillor mrs butcher
yes can you hear me now
hello
thank you um i'll come back to
mrs council mrs butcher can you hear me
councilor butcher
yes i can can you hear me yes which way
would you like to vote yes
counselor counselor mrs gooding thank
you
and councillor hookway can you hear me
now
thank you
okay
members i can clear can come declare
that counselor mrs goodin is a winner by
25 votes for
uh and for her and nine uh for
councillor wilkinson
thank you members
council wilkinson you wish to say a few
words
thank you chairman yes um i i actually
put my hand up before the vote because i
what i was going to say is slightly um
the wrong way around now unfortunately
um i thank you for the opportunity to
speak i i want to just wanted to to say
to members generally through you
chairman if i may
um and sort of echo some of the comments
that the other
minority group leaders said uh earlier
on about the inclusiveness
which we're all trying to seek um
now the paperwork that the monitoring
officer sent out
gave guidance around the chairmanships
of committees um
using the pro articles and quite rightly
suggests that
or even says i should say that the pro
articles don't in fact have to be
adhered to
but if they were to be then it gives
guidance as to what the
the nominations should look like um
and it's it's not it's not a it's not a
secret chairman that fiction does exist
within membership of this council which
is sad
um and and and i'm not naive to the fact
that it's going to disappear overnight
however
i would question chairman if there's any
uh wonder why there is a degree of
cynicism which does exist sadly from
some minority group members when
we do feel excluded um from things and
and we're refused to be allowed to be
involved
um to the same extent now
the the guidance that was sent out by
the monitoring officer suggests
that the chairmanships of the council
should look like
um six conservative one liberal
democrats
one rochelle district resident and one
green party in fairness
my group shouldn't get one and the
nominations as they look like at the
moment
and i and i want to make this quite
clear to both you mr chairman and also
to all members listening
but when i look at the names that are
written down there i don't have a
problem with any of them because i think
they're all professional
um and would all do an excellent job i
have absolutely no doubt and
congratulations to council mrs gooding
for the appointment
that she's just been given um but i
my my reason for wanting to speak
chairman is
is really through fairness and to try
and and be more inclusive
and to ask the administration to be more
inclusive of other members of this
council
um because at the moment if if what it
looks like goes through there will be
eight conservative councillors and one
nominated by the conservative group
without any
uh minority member being allowed
anywhere near a seat so
chairman i would invite members just to
consider that as we go forward
with the next two votes for the review
committee and the vice chairmanship
thank you
thank you uh councillor wilkinson i
thank you uh for your comments
members i shall now pass you back again
to angela law to continue with this item
chairman so for the chairman of review
committee members asked
are asked to indicate if they want to
vote for councillor burton or council
hawkway
members again i shall conduct that via a
call roll call of names
and if you can please indicate whether
you wish to vote for councillor burton
or councillor hawkway
councillor mr chairman on a point of
order
are we where is the ability to make this
a recorded vote
it is still a motion this is just a part
of something within the overall motion
so you should be able to we should be
able to request a recorded vote still
council mr hoy i shall allow a vote
for a recorded vote for those who
require it so
members if you completely indicate when
indicating who you wish to vote for
as to whether you wish to have a
recorded vote
thank you
councillor mrs belton
no recorded vote and i vote councillor
burton
councillor mrs butcher
no recorded vote and i vote for council
councillor burton
thank you councillor mr carter
yeah no recorded vote and councillor
burn
myself councillor drano recorded vote
and councillor burton
councillor ft no recorded vote and
councillor burton please
councillor eves recorded vote and
councillor thank you councillor mrs
gooding
no recorded vote and i vote for
councillor burton
thank you chairman thank you councillor
hazelwood
nolan burton
did you want a recorded vote or no
recorded vote counselor hook way
yes yes hyde
recorded vote and for councillor hawkway
thank you councillor hudson no recorded
vote
councillor burton thank you councillor
ionu
i record a vote hawkway councillor
mr lucas gill no recorded vote
councillor burton councillor mrs lumley
no and councillor burton thank you
councillor mrs mason
recorded vote and counselor neil hookway
thank you councillor mrs mcpherson
no recorded vote please chairman and
councillor jamie burton
thank you councilmerrick no
councillor burton thank you councilman
no recorded vote and councillor burton
thank you
council newport yeah i mean if i may um
if we don't get the recorded vote i'd
like my vote recorded in the minutes but
i vote for
um a recorded vote and for councillor
neil hookway
thank you councillor mrs pavlin
i recorded foe and councillor burton
please thank you council mrs rowe
thank you chairman no and councillor
burton
thank you councillor mr shaw
mrs shaw sorry yeah mrs shaw councillor
mrs shaw
thank you no recorded vote and
councillor
mr person thank you mr shaw
no recorded vote councillor person mr
smith
no recorded vote and councillor burton
thank you council sparing no recorded
vote
councillor burton also stanley
a recorded vote please chairman and uh
neil hookway thank you
council board
i think you met i think you missed out
councillor steptoe
but for me so no recorded vote and
councillor
burton please how's the step toe
apologies for leaving you out
no recorded vote and councillor burton
thank you
council webb no recorded vote and
councillor burton please chairman
thank you councillor mrs weston very
recorded vote and council burtons
chairman thank you councillor mr
wilkinson
uh recorded vote please chairman and
councillor neil hookway
thank you council williams no recording
no recording vote and councillor burton
please councillor wilson
a recorded vote and council hallway and
if there is no recorded vote
could i have my vote recorded as uh
going against council hallway please
thank you councillor wootton no recorded
votes
chairman and councillor burton thank you
members there will be a recorded vote 25
votes
were for counselor burton and
nine for councillor hookway
so councillor hogway is the
sorry councillor burton my apologies
wins that round thank you
members i shall now pass you back again
to angela law
thank you um chairman so for the vice
chairman
of the standards committee members are
asked to indicate if they want to vote
for
councillor mrs lumley or councillor
stanley
members once
members um i will
confirm the vote via roll call of names
can you please indicate whether you wish
to have a recorded vote
or you wish to vote for councillor mrs
lumley or
councillor stanley
councillor mrs belton no recorded vote
in councillor lumley councillor mrs
butcher
no recorded vote and councillor mrs
lumley thank you councillor mr carter
no recorded vote and council and mrs
lumley
thank you myself councillor draynor
recorded vote
and counts the lumley councillor efti
no recording votes and council alumni
councillor eves recorded vote and
councillor stanley thank you
thank you councillor mrs gooding no
recorded vote
and for councillor june lumley thank you
thank you
councillor hazelwood
more than council lumley thank you
councillor hookway
thank you council mr hoyer
for a recorded vote and for councillor
stanley
thank you councillor hudson no recorded
vote
councillor june lumley thank you
councillor
no recorded votes councillor stanley
councillor mr lucas gill no recorded
vote
and council and this is lovely thank you
councillor mrs lumley
no recorded vote and councillor mrs
longley
thank you councillor mrs mason
recorded vote and counselor chris
stanley
thank you councillor mrs mcpherson
no recorded vote and counselor june
lumley please
thank you councillor merrick
no recorded vote councillor mrs lumley
thank you counselor milne no recorded
vote and councillor june lundley
thank you council newport recorded vote
and councillor chris stanley councillor
mrs pavlin
no recorded vote and councillor june
rumley
mrs rowe thank you chairman no recorded
vote
and counsellor mrs june lumley thank you
councillor mrs shaw
no recorded vote and mrs june lumley
thank you
councillor mrs june lumley sorry thank
you
mr shaw no recorded vote counsellor
mrs june lumley thank you councillor
smith
no recorded vote councillor mrs lumley
also sparing no recorded vote council
mrs lumley
now sir stanley recorded vote please and
book councillor chris stanley thank you
council steptoe
no recorded vote and councillor june
london thank you council ward
no recording vote and councillor mrs
lundley
councillor webb no recorded vote and
councillor gene nominee
councillor mrs weston no recorded voting
council
chairman thank you council wilkinson
chairman and councillor chris stanley
thank you
councillor williams thank you chairman
no recorded vote and councillor mrs
lumley
thank you councillor wootton no recorded
vote and councillor mrs lovely
councillor wilson my apologies i missed
you out
thank you chairman um for a recorded
vote
and for councillor chris stanley thank
you
members there will be a recorded vote
and i'd like to confirm that councillor
mrs june lumley will be vice chairman of
the standards committee
25 votes four and uh
nine votes uh for council stanley
stanley thank you very much
i shall now pass you back um to angela
law
thank you chairman can members disagree
the appointment of the chairman
and vice chairman of committees has set
out on page
11.19 of redemption and subject to the
appointment of counseling mrs goodwin as
chairman of
the licensing and appeals committee
councillor burton as chairman of the
committee and councillor mrs lumley as
vice chairman of standards committee
members once again to confirm the
agreement
i will do a roll call of names when i
call your name can you please indicate
whether you require recorded vote
or if you're voting for or against
endorsement the chairman stroke vice
chairman of committees
are set out in addendum 2 and subject to
the appointment
of councillor
good mrs gooding as chairman of
licensing and appeals committee
councillor burton as chairman of the
review committee
and councillor
mrs lumley as vice chairman of the
standards committee
members counselor mrs belton
no recorded vote and four thank you
councilor mrs butcher
no recorded vote and four thank you
chairman
councillor mr carter yeah no recorded
vote
and four thank you chairman myself no
no recorded vote and four councillor fd
no recording vote and four thank you
thank you councillor eves
boarded vote and abstain thank you
councillor mrs gooding no recorded vote
and four thank you chairman thank you
councillor hazelwood
no one for thank you councillor hawkway
can you repeat that please council
hawkway
recorded your vote for a recorded vote i
hope that's right
councillor mr hoy for a recorded vote
and against thank you councillor hudson
no recorded vote and four councillor
ionu
no recorded vote and four council
mr lucas gill no recorded vote
and four councillor mrs lumley
oh and four councillor mrs mason
recorded vote against thank you
councillor mrs mcpherson
no and for thank you chairman thank you
council merrick
councillor merrick
i'll come back to you as councillor
merrick councillor milne
no recorded vote and four council
newport
for a recorded vote and against
council mrs pavlin no no
i'm paul thank you councillor mrs rowe
thank you chairman no recorded vote and
four
council mrs shaw thank you chair no
recorded vote
and four councillor mr shaw
no recorded vote and fought that's a
sparing
no recorded bowdoin for council stanley
a recorded vote and against thank you
councilman smith no recorded vote and
four
stanley
a recorded vote and against
the answer no recorded vote
and four thank you council ward
no and four chairman and councillor
merrick is now back
on track okay i'll come back to council
american good time
councillor mrs weston no recorded
vote chairman four thank you councillor
wilkinson
no recorded vote to chairman sorry a
recorded vote please chairman and said
him against the motion
okay councillor williams no recorded
vote and four thank you chairman
council wilson for a recorded vote and
against chairman
councillor woodson no recorded vote and
four
thank you councillor webb
thank you chairman no and four thank you
encounter merrick
thank you jim uh no and four thank you
it is if i may just mention uh chairman
my connection uh internet connection
does seem to be
unstable at the moment my apologies if i
come and go
okay councilman eric thank you for
letting us know
members there will be a recorded vote
there were 25
votes for of the motion seven against
a one abstention thank you members
muted yeah sorry i'll come back to as
soon as i can members
recommendation five that counselor mrs
leslie butcher
be appointed as the armed forces
covenant champion for the
2020 21 municipal year
members i should again uh confirm that
via a roll call of names if you can
indicate whether you're for
or against or require recorded votes
counselor mrs belton
no recorded vote for
councillor mrs butcher no recorded vote
m4 council mr carter
no recorded vote and four myself
councillor drayno recorded vote and four
councillor fd yes to recorded vote and
four
councillor eves sorry can you just
confirm
the uh motion it wasn't very clear on
the audio i could hear angelo muttering
in the background but that was about it
it's recommendation 5 it's
recommendation
five councillor eves
sorry chairman can you come back to me
counselor is uh angela will read the
read it out again for you chairman the
recommendation is on page 11.4
it's recommendation five and it is that
councillor mrs butcher be appointed as
the armed forces covenant champion for
the 2020
21 municipal year how do you vote
councillor eves
no recorded vote for thank you thank you
thank you uh councillor mrs gooding
no recorded vote and four thank you
chairman
that's the heiser word 114
councillor hawkway
we'll come back to your council hawkway
councillor mr hoy
now recorded councillor hudson
no recorded vote and four thank you
councillor ionu
no recorded vote and four councillor
mr lucas gill no
recorded vote and four mrs lumley
no and for thank you councillor mrs
mason
no recorded vote mr chairman and for the
motion thank you
thank you councillor mrs mcpherson i
recorded vote and for the motion thank
you
councillor merrick no and four
thank you councillor milne
no recorded vote and four council
newport
no and four councillor mrs pavlin
councillor mrs rowe thank you chairman
no and
four thank you councillor mrs shaw
thank you miss chairman known for
councillor mr shaw
no and for councillor smith
no recorded vote and counselor sparing
no and for council stanley
no and abstain the answer step toe
no and are very pleased to support this
motion thank you council award
no and for chairman thank you council
webb
no and four thank you chairman council
mrs weston
i recorded vote chairman and four thank
you
thank you council wilkinson no one for
channel
thank you council williams uh no and
four thank you chairman
thank you council wilson no and abstain
thank you council wooden no recorded
vote and
four thank you thank you council hawkway
can you hear me
if i could ask you for your vote please
thank you councillor hookway
uh
uh members there is no recorded vote
31 for the motion and three against
thank you members that has been agreed
yeah sorry just a point of order um
could you just check that because i'm
sure
a number of uh members abstained didn't
hear you mention their names
just make sure you've got the right
numbers
council wilkinson there were three
abstentions
sorry i do apologize i thought you said
three against and thirty-one four i
didn't hear you mentioned the extensions
i
apologize yeah
members i shall now take item 14
on the agenda this is the appointment of
representatives to outside bodies
and other forums 2020 stroke 21
and again angela law will present this
item
thank you chairman council is required
to set up
on pages 14.3 and 14.4 of the report
the first recommendation is for the
appointment of officers and portfolio
holders to outside bodies
for the 2020-21 municipal year on the
basis set out on page
14.5 of appendix 1 to this report
and the appointees are listed in the
dental one on page 14.8
that is to be agreed chairman thank you
members to obtain your agreement again
i will ask for a roll call of names when
i call your name can you please
chairman there are three members
indicating to speak
bear with me
thank you um i'm going to keep this
brief and it really
moves on chairman to from where i spoke
last time about the the
chairmanships of the various committees
um
the when looking at the
the only one i want to make reference to
chairman is the river crouch coastal
community team steering group
um which has four nominations for two
seats um
councillor george yuanu um
is one of the four nominations nominated
by myself and himself but our group
um he has previously been in this
position he's held this position for the
last number of years voted in
by the conservative group each time
whilst a conservative member
i can only assume um the fact that he's
not being supported
uh this time is because he's no longer a
conservative member
um which is slightly sad but um
but the the administration wouldn't
consider having the right man for the
job as opposed to just with the right
color
um and to use a footballing analogy if i
may it's
almost like if somebody runs a football
team and and wants me as their striker
because i'm no footballer and along
comes cristiano ronaldo who offers his
services free of charge
as a striker but the manager refuses and
chooses me because i'm on his team
um and ronaldo isn't it's just it's just
lunacy and and
so again chairman with regressive
respect i'm not suggesting
that the nominations that have been put
forward by your group
for that particular post are inadequate
in any way shape or form
but i think councillor juan who has a
proven track record there he is
supported by the crouch river authority
they have contacted the council
themselves
to support him going forward um and and
i i would
strongly urge members please to support
him uh continuing to represent rochester
council on that
body thank you council wilkinson i thank
you for your comments
uh councillor mr hoyer thank you
chairman you're probably not surprised
to hear that i will have similar remarks
to council
wilkinson um i there's two points i'd
like to make one
i'll make the general point first then
i'll specific in a minute
the the general point is that over
recent years we as opposition members
of fate face what we would consider
unfair criticism from
the administration members about our
inability to
join in with them and to participate
however we do try to participate we do
put
nominations forward to chairman and vice
chairman of committees
and we put forward nominees to outside
bodies as we have done this year
i myself in earlier days in 2011
uh as i've said already councillor terry
cutwood
i spoke to him and he said yesterday we
will do that he appointed me to the
richard housing association for four
years
um also i seem to remember councillor
mrs um macpherson
suggested i was um in my naivety at the
time put myself forward for the
chairmanship of a committee
and she suggested outside body and she
suggested
i'd be the substitute member which was
very good i
so we have been there in the past and
not the too distant past
and i think perhaps it would be good if
um councillor wooten may consider this
with his um
group at some point that we can
contribute and just because we are
minority
parties doesn't mean that that we aren't
able to
um that's the general point and i think
other members may will agree with me
the specific point is on the item 14
revised addendum
7 which came out today 14.16
and this is for the river crouch coastal
community team
i suppose there's two points really at
the moment i can't see anyone
who's been nominated who actually lives
in a world which actually bounds
the river crouch and the second point is
and hopefully
counselor would've might be able to
answer this is that one of the two
appointees
for this is the portfolio holder for
enterprise
at the moment the portfolio holder for
enterprise does not exist
because it's not being filled at the
moment can counselor wouldn't
say who that would be at this point in
time
prior to that being filled thank you
sorry german you're muted
counsellors i shall ask councillor
woodson to respond to that
a little later but the next to speak is
councillor mrs
mason mrs mason
thank you mr chairman you'll not be
surprised to hear that what i'm
going to say is along the same lines the
previous vote has just demonstrated
the issues that council wilkinson so
eloquently summed up
when he spoke about the frustration
minority groups feel
when the administration excludes them
and yet criticizes them
less than two days ago actually for not
participating
this contradiction is neither
constructive
or welcome we accept the right of the
administration to choose
we don't accept the right of it to
exclude
and then criticize thank you
thank you councillor mrs mason
councillor woodson
thank you very much indeed uh for giving
the opportunity to
come back on one or two of the points um
certainly i mean in relation to the
previous item what we've just gone
through is a fairly lengthy process
where nominations have been put forward
and by virtue
of the way dare i say politics works up
and down the country
this is a a common point which is made
against administrations
and but uh i've been leader for all of
about an
hour now um i actually uh
welcome the opportunity over a period of
time to
ensure that across the chamber um
we do um embrace and
work positively with our opposition
uh partners but uh working with our
opposition partners
also carries with it uh responsibility
and we will
do everything we can to embrace harmony
where that is possible but coming back
to the specifics that
um in relation to the river crouch
coastal
community team steering group i think
with the greatest of respect
councillor mike wilkinson may be getting
a little confused with that than the
crouch harbour authority
the crouch river crouch coastal
community team steering group
is actually a recently adopted group
that we actually inherited from malden
and
they were the administrators and in
writing out the terms of reference for
that group
it was agreed that actually and i accept
that there's a little bit of confusion
on the revised addendum
but it was agreed within those terms of
reference
that the nominees would be chairman mrs
june lumley and the second member there
would be defined as the portfolio holder
for enterprise
i have to take issue in the sense that
that has only been formed as a group
since i took over as portfolio holder
for enterprise
it did not exist at the time uh
under the same constitution when
councillor iron
was the portfolio holder for enterprise
but i take the point
um and in terms of
the so council mrs lumley
it was agreed by the actual group was
the chair
uh and the designated post second post
is the portfolio holder for enterprise
and it may be that officers need to just
refer back to the terms of reference
just to check
that i am correct there and the nominees
for uh substitutes are defined
actually as the portfolio holder for
environment if the portfolio holder for
enterprise cannot attend
and for councillor mrs shaw to attend if
councillor mrs lumley is not able so
hopefully i can clear that one up
but in terms of inclusivity i spent some
time last week recognizing
the excellent work that councillor iona
has done with the crouch harbour
authority which is a separate
organization
i spent some time negotiating with the
chairman of that authority
to organise councillor ionu in a
permanent place there
so i'm delighted to say that his good
work has been recognized
and i personally worked with the
chairman of the crouch harbour authority
to ensure that he has a permanent
position
along with myself as the portfolio
holder for enterprise
i have retained one or two functions and
that will be one of them pending the
review that i talked about earlier
chairman thank you very much indeed
chairman you're still on thank you
councillor wooden for those comments
council wilkinson you wish to speak
kevin thank you very briefly
um just to acknowledge what the leader
has just said
just to thank him for his comments and
apologize for my mistake
um and uh i acknowledge the the efforts
he's done on behalf of councillor
thank you council wilkinson members i
shall now take
the vote um and again um i shall do that
by a roll call please indicate when i
call your name whether you wish to
record
a recorded vote if you're voting for or
against endorsement the policy holder
appointments
as set out in addendum one
councillor belton
no recorded vote for council
mrs butcher so chairman could
you explain exactly what we're voting
for now
because there are a number of different
nominees are we just
voting for the administration's nominees
or this is in respect of
item 14 recommendation one
i shall read it out again for the sake
of clarity
council is required to make the
decisions set out on pages 14.3
and 14.4 of the report the first
recommendation is for the appointment of
officers
and portfolio holders to outside bodies
for the 2020-21
municipal year on the basis to set out
on page
14.5 of appendix 1 to this report
and the appointees are listed in
addendum 1 on page 14.8
hope that's clearer right
sorry again what were we voting for is
this
is the recorded vote
uh you can vote for a recorded vote if
you wish
no no recorded vote and i agree with um
this 14 point what we're voting on thank
you
vote and for the motion yes yes
yeah no recorded vote and ford emotion
thank you chairman
counselor no recorded vote and for the
motion
councillor fd i'd like your recorded
votes and for the motion
thank you councillor eves will you vote
and abstain
thank you chairman councillor mrs
gooding
no recorded vote and for the motion
thank you chairman
councillor mr hazelwood
no recorded vote and abstain thank
no and abstain thank you we've got
there's no an abstain council hookway
yes
councillor mr hoyer no recorded vote and
abstain
thank you abstaining please
thank you councillor mr hudson no
recorded vote
and for recommendation one and may i
please bring to your attention the time
yes councillor ionu
no recorded voting for
councillor mr lucas gill no recorded
vote
and four councillor mrs lumley
no and for councillor mrs mason
thank you mr chairman no recorded vote
and for appendix one thank you
council mrs mcpherson
recorded vote i'm four thank you
councillor merrick
councilor merrick
i'll come back to you councillor merrick
councillor mill
no recorded vote and four council
newport
council newport
come back to your council newport
councillor mrs pavlin
9 4 thank you councillor mrs rowe
thank you chairman no to recorded vote
and four
thank you councillor mrs shaw no to
recorded vote
and four thank you councillor mrs shaw
mr shaw no recorded vote and four
sorry cancer mr shaw council mrs mr
smith sorry it's been a long day
counsellor mr smith no recorded vote and
four
counts of sparing no recorded vote and
four
yes sir stanley
recorded vote against
councillor steptoe
no and for councillor ward
chairman no and four and councillor
david merrick is back on track
thank you i'll come back to him
councillor webb no recorded vote and
four thank you councillor mrs weston
i recorded voting for chairman council
wilkinson
94 chairman council williams
a recorded vote and four thank you
chairman councillor wilson
no recorded vote and against
council merrick are you back on track
thank you chairman apologies for leaving
for a few few seconds
um yes uh no and four
thank you council newport
are you with us
no council woodson
no recorded vote and thank you very much
um
members there are 26 votes for
two against and for abstentions
and that member's item has been agreed
thank you
you
recorded
members it's now um
9 47 coming up to two and a half hours
of the meeting um i shall ask
for a vote as to whether you wish
the meeting to be extended and again
that will be done by
roll call i shall ask you if you want a
recorded vote
or vote for or against
an extension okay um
just to uh put you in the picture we are
still
going through item 14
um and unfortunately due to an oversight
um we have i have
missed items 12 and 13.
i intend should you agree to extension
to carry on
with item 14 and see how we go with
items 12 and 13.
all right i shall now do a roll call
councillor belton
no recorded vote and extend
count councillor mrs butcher
no recorded vote and extend
councillor mr carter yeah no recorded
any extension
for myself no recorded vote and
extension
counselor fd now recorded an extension
thank you councillor eves uh no recorded
vote and
stop i started at five o'clock this
morning i'm absolutely
at the end
hawkway
for a recorded vote and against
extension
councillor mr hudson no recorded vote
and no extension councillor ionu
councillor ionu
come back to you account uh can you hear
me now
no recorded vote and uh no extension
thank you councillor mr lucas gill
no to a recorded vote and no extension
counselor mrs lumley no recorded vote
and no
extension counselor mrs mason
recorded vote no extension and mr
chairman as a
point of order you've just said
extension you haven't said for how long
thank you yeah i'll come back to you
council mrs mason
councillor mrs mcpherson um no recorded
vote and no extension thank you merrick
that's america come back to you
councillor meal no recorded vote and no
extension
council newport
thank you
thank you chairman no and extension
please can you tell me chairman if this
doesn't go through when we will be
finishing this business
i will let you know councillor yes
counselor mrs shaw uh no recording vote
and for extension and i would also like
clarification when this is going to be
carrick when we can carry this
uh forward thank you if we don't do an
installation
no recorded vote and for extension
council smith no recorded vote and four
suspending no recorded voting for
councillor steptoe no recorded vote
against
council stanley there will be no or both
accounts thank you
council ward
no and for an extension bounce to the
web
no and for an extension the answer
misses western
no recorded voting for extension
chairman councillor wilkinson
no and against jim councillor williams
oh and four thank you chairman council
wilson
no and against chairman councilwood
thank you excuse me mr chairman
you've got me okay so that's the mrs
gooden
gooding how do you vote an extension
please
thank you
council merrick can you hear me thank
you chairman
um no and for an extension
thank you we'll come back to you man
uh
the messages members um
there are seven 17 votes for an
extension
16 votes against an extension so we will
carry on
and i intend to monitor that as we go
ahead go along
uh i lost
for an extension 16 against
an extension so we will carry on
past 10 o'clock and i shall review the
situation
nearer to 10 30. i shall ask angela law
to carry on with the gender item 14.
chairman could we have a comfort break
please
um you're in your own home
counselor i know
okay gentlemen i'm sorry to say that i'm
going to have to leave the meeting
okay thank you
councillor ionu uh and members i shall
adjourn the meeting for five minutes
for a comfort break during which time
tim and i should be leaving
sorry
chairman i shall be leaving the meeting
at
in five minutes thank you
i shall be leaving the meeting also
hey
this is doing me no good whatsoever
me no good whatsoever
nice
chairman i know i went for an extension
but i think i'll have to leave because
i've got an early morning run in the
morning
very sorry
and i've had to put it back on charge
excuse me david your phone is not muted
we can hear what you're saying
dive sparing yes thank you
members can i um uh remind members that
we're still on live screenings
streaming um and any members
that uh gone for a comfort break could i
ask them to come back as quickly as
possible because the five minutes is
nearly up thank you
i like this
sorry
can i really hear a cuckoo yeah
[ __ ] clock super
yeah um don't worry um councillor has
another few hours and it'll be
um the dawn for us members
um we will continue um
with the meeting i think everybody's
back
counselor mrs mason i understand you
wish to speak
counselor mrs mason
her hand's not up on the thing anymore
if it was
she's muted can we carry on please
chairman
we will please your counsel mrs mason if
you can uh
hear me yes sorry mr chairman
it's not very easy doing this is it um
mr chairman my apologies but at the
lateness of the i'm not prepared to
continue i think that
it's wrong with us to put our health at
risk in this situation
so i wish you well good night thank you
chairman stanley speaking i'm sorry i'm
gonna have to leave the meeting now
and i'll wish you the best you can get
on with
okay bye
members we shall carry on with item 14 i
shall pass you
over to angela law
the recommendation too is for the
appointment of member representatives
including a number of substitutes for
the
20 21 municipal year to the outside
bodies set out on pages
14.6 and 14.7 of appendix 2 to this
report
the named bodies and the nominations
received to them are set out in addendum
2 to the report
on pages 14.9 to 14.10
that is to be chairman subject to
dealing them with multiple nominations
that
that have been received for some of the
outside bodies
to take these in turn nominations have
been received for councillor williams
and councillor hogway
for the essex flood partnership board
can members please indicate if they want
to vote for council williams or
councillor hookway thank you
members again there will be a roll call
of names please indicate
if you wish to have a recorded vote
or vote before councillor hawkway my
sound seemed to go then so i didn't
quite hear all of all of
what was read out could it be just be
reread please
chairman the appointment of member
representatives including
a number of substitutes for the 2020-21
municipal year
to the outside bodies set out on pages
14.6 and 14.7
of appendix 2 to this report the
named bodies and the nominations
received to them are set out in addendum
2 to the report on pages 14.9 to 14.10
that is to be agreed chairman subject to
the dealing uh with multiple nominations
that
have been received for some of the
outside bodies to take and
i will be taking these in turn
nominations have been received for
councillor williams and councillor
hawkway for with essex flood partnership
board
can members please indicate if they want
to vote for council williams or for
council hawkwood thank you chairman
members i shall take
a roll call of names as normal please
indicate whether you wish to have a
recorded vote
or should you wish to vote for council
williams or councillor hookway
yeah councillor mrs belton
no recording councillor williams thank
you
councillor mrs butcher
now recorded and councillor williams
thank you councillor mr carter
um myself no recorded uh vote
and i vote for councillor williams
councillor fd
sorry i would like a recorded vote and
councillor williams please
thank you councillor eves
councillor gooding no recorded vote
and for councillor williams thank you mr
chairman
thank you council hazelwood
no williams councillor hookway
no we're no longer with us council of mr
highway
thank you councillor
can you hear me lots of members seem to
have their mics unmuted and it's making
it very difficult to hear
councillor hawkway can you hear me
a recorded vote councillor williams
councillor io no recorded votes cancel
williams
council mr lucas gill no recorded vote
councillor williams mrs lumley i think
she's left us councillor mrs mason has
left us councillor mrs macpherson
no and councillor williams yesterday
oh councillor williams councillor milner
no and councillor williams council
newport
councillor mrs pavlin no
in council councillor williams thank you
councillor mrs rowe
thank you chairman no and councillor
williams
councillor mrs shaw no i'm captain
councillor mr williams thank you
councillor mr shaw no and council
williams
council smith no recorded vote
councillor williams
bouncer sparing no council williams
council stanley has left us councillor
steptoe
council ward no and councillor williams
place
council webb no and councillor williams
council mr preston no he called invoking
councillor mr williams please
councillor wilkinson
no and uh castle hookwood please thank
you councillor williams
for myself please thank you no recorded
vote council wilson
no and councillor hookway councillor
whatton
no and councillor williams
yes councillor mr hoy we did
you did give us your vote in your
council mr hoyer yes i
did thank you very much chairman peter
please for the record
yes it was no to a recorded vote and for
councillor hawkway thank you
and sorry chairman i also did ask for my
cat vote to be
recorded
councillor hoy well we will note that
council wilkinson can you
confirm again your vote please uh my
vote
was where my vote was for councillor
hook away and i'm not uh asking for a
recorded phone
thank you
members um there were 23
no recorded vote 23 votes for
council williams and four
for councillor hawkway so the vote goes
to
councillor williams thank you very much
over to
angela law thank you chairman
nominations
have been received for councillor carter
council of mrs weston and councillor
eads for the hockley community centre
association council
uh chairman i believe council mrs weston
would like to speak on this
okay
oh yes thank you chairman um if it
please the leader i'm quite happy to um
withdraw my nomination and let uh
councillor eve take my
take my place thank you chairman okay
in that case members there's no need for
a vote counselor
thank you mrs councillor mrs weston
back to count angela law chairman i will
move on to the
london south bend airport consultative
committee
nominations have been received for
councillor fd councillor lucas gill
council award and councillor mrs carter
for three appointments
can the members please indicate if they
want to
vote for councillor fd uh
councillor lucas gill council award or
councillor carter
members um i would stress that that is
counselor mrs carter
for the three uh yes yes yes okay
again members i shall take of uh roll
call you know the
uh role uh the procedure now uh
recorded vote for or against those three
and that's
councillor efti councillor lucas gill
council award
or councillor mrs carter
chairman can i just clarify this so we
won't for you want free names who we're
voting for
correct thank you
councillor mrs belton no recorded vote
fd lucas gill and wald
okay um councillor mrs butcher
no recorded vote and fd lucas gill
and councillor ian ward
thank you
councillor dre that's myself no recorded
vote i'm voting for councillor fd
councillor lucas gill
and council award councillor fd
uh a recorded vote and fd lucas gill and
ward please
chairman
he's left councillor gooding no recorded
vote
and councillor fd councillor lucas gill
and council award thank you very much
chairman
thank you councillor hazelwood
your recorded vote fd lucas gillan ward
thank you councillor hookway
no recorded vote and for councillor mrs
carter i'd like my vote recorded please
thank you councillor hudson no recorded
vote
sorry no recording vote
councillors fd lucas gill and
ward thank you councillor iodo
no recorded vote fd
ward and carter thank you councillor mr
lucas gill
no recorded vote councillors fd
lucas gill and ward mrs lumley
councilman mrs lumley and mrs
mason has left councillor mrs mcpherson
no
in councillors fd lucas gil ward thank
you councillor merrick
no councillors
thank you councillor mrs pavlin
uh no uh councillors fd
lucas gil and walt thank you thank you
council newport has left
councillor mrs rowe thank you chairman
now and councillors fd lucas gill and
ward
thank you councilman mr shaw thank you
mr chairman
um fd lucas gill and ward thank you very
much
thank you councillor mr shaw no
and councillors fd lucas gillum ward
thank you council smith
no recorded vote councillors fd lucas
gill and ward
thank you councillor stanley and steptoe
have left
council award uh no recorded vote
uh councillors fd lucas gill and ward
answer sparing
cancer sparing you're muted
dave
i'll come back to your counter sparing
council web
no and councillors fd lucas gill and
walt
thank you chairman councillor mrs weston
no no no recording vote uh counts as fd
councillors
guilt and council award please chairman
council wilkinson
uh no recorded vote thank you chairman
um councillor
daniel lefty councillor ian ward and
councillor mrs tony carter
thank you councillor williams thank you
chairman no recorded vote and
councillors
fd lucas gill and ward thank you thank
you council
wilson no and councillor tony carter
thank you councillor wootton no recorded
vote chairman councillors fd lucas gill
and
ward council sparing can you hear me now
can you hear me
now yes yeah no recording vote counts as
fd lucas gilmore
council hookway i'll try you again can
you hear me please
yes we can just about
very cool
yeah thank you thank you members
members there's no recorded vote um we
have
22 votes each of our councillors fd
lucas gil and ward
and five for councillor mrs carter
the three that go forward are
councillors fd lucas guild
and ward thank you members i shall pass
you back to
angela law chairman nominations have
been received for councillor milne and
councillor mrs
carter for the rayleigh mount local
committee can members please indicate
they want to vote for councillor mill
milne or councillor mrs carter
members again the roll call and again
you can go vote for
a recorded vote or uh
councillors mrs carter please indicate
when i call your name counselor mrs
belton
no recorded vote and councillor milne
thank you councillor mrs butcher
no recorded vote and counsellor milne
uh mr carter's gone councillors carter
no mrs carter
myself no recorded vote and councillor
mill
councillor fd recorded votes and
councillor milne
councillor mr eves he's gone
he's
no recorded vote and councillor milne
thank you chairman
thank you councillors councillor
hazelwood
nolan milne thank you council hawkway
thank you mr hall
no recorded vote and for councillor mrs
carter thank you councillor hudson
no recording vote and councillor milne
thank you councillor iodu no recorded
vote
councillor carter thank you councillor
mr lucas gill
no and councillor middle okay
councillors lovely and councillors mason
has left us councillor mrs mcpherson
no end counselor milne thank you
councilman merrick
no and council of neon councils thank
you councillor milne
no and councillor milne councillor mrs
pavlin
uh now and counselling neil
thank you councilman councillor mrs rowe
thank you chairman no and councilman
councillor mrs shaw no i'm counsellor mr
real
councillor mr shaw no and councillor
milne
council smith now recorded vote
councillor milne
thank you sparing
no councillor milne thank you council
stanley and steptoe have left us council
wall
yeah it's noah and councillor meown
chairman
council webb no and councillor milne
thank you chairman
thank you councillor mrs
council wilkinson
no and councillor mrs carter thank you
council wilson
council wilson
council woodson no and councillor milner
williams councillor williams
no and councillor milne thank you
uh my apologies chairman i'm going to
have to leave the meeting now
uh thank you
members um the vote is 21 votes no
recorded votes
no recorded results results 21 for
councillor milne
and four for council mrs carter so the
vote goes
for to councillor meal members
i'm conscious of the time it's now 21
minutes past
10. we still have a number of items to
go through
okay and i would imagine they would take
at least another
30 minutes and we still have items 12
and 13 to go through
so i should take another vote as to
whether members wish to
carry on to be clear if we are not
extending then these matters will go to
next week's meeting yes did you hit or
hear that
if these items aren't clear this evening
they will go to next tuesday's meeting
okay right so we're voting for an
extension
and i shall review it again near 11
o'clock if an extension is agreed
counselor mrs meltz at belton
no recording for extending
thank you councillor mrs butcher
no recorded against extending
uh myself no recorded
a foreign extension counselor fd
no recording for extension
counselor mrs gooding no recording
for extension thank you chairman
councillor hazelwood
glory calling against extension
councillor hawkway
that was against we recorded that as
against an extension councillor hudson
and no recording and uh
against extension council
councillor ionu no extent
no extension uh no recording
counselor mr lucas gill no
um recording and no to an extension
counselor mrs mcpherson no recorded vote
and no to an extension
counselor mr merrick you're on mute
david sorry
sorry chairman uh no and no thank you
councillor mill uh no and yes
councillor mrs cleveland
uh no no no i'm gonna have to go i'm
sorry
councillor mrs rowe thank you chairman
no and
extension please counselor mrs shawn
recorded vote and yes to the extension
council no
and yes and i think you've missed out to
councillor sparing
council sparing no and yes
councillor mrs weston uh we call you
vote and no to extinction
no it's a recorded vote and i know how
busy our
gender is on tuesday so yes to an
extension thank you council williams
for a chairman no and yes to the
extension
council wilson
has a leftist california
yes
there is no uh recorded vote members
the vote is 13 for an extension
and 12 against so we shall continue
and i shall review again
i'm gonna have to go okay
thank you councillor pavlin good night
yeah that's fine
thank you good night
thank you nominations have been received
for councillor fd and councillor ease
for the rocha100 association
of local councils can members please
indicate if they want to vote for
councillor fd or councillor eves
right members is councillor fd or
councillor eves
the rochford hundred association uh you
know the procedure now
if i call your names uh can you vote for
either councillor fd or councillor eves
counsellor mrs burton belton sorry
councillor mrs belton
no recorded vote and councillor fd
myself uh no recorded vote and
councillor fd
councillor efti no recording vote nft
council mrs gooding no recorded vote and
councillor fd
thank you chairman councillor hazelwood
noah lefty councillor hudson
no recorded vote councillor fd
councillor iono no recorded vote council
eve
councillor mr lucas gill no can we vote
councillor fd thank you councillor mrs
mcphawson
no an abstain councillor merrick
hello and counselor fd councillor milne
no and councillor fd councillor mrs
pavlin
she's gone she's gone thank you
councillor mrs rowe
thank you chairman no and councillor fd
councillor mrs shaw
no one counselor councillor mr shaw
now on council lefty council smith
i recorded vote councillor fd thank you
council sparing
no no an fd councillor wald
no fd council webb
no and councillor fd councillor weston
harry cory and council lefty council
wilkinson uh no record about councillor
eves please chairman
councillor williams no recorded vote on
council danny lefty please
go and councillor after
chairman you've forgot me
okay man sorry counselor butcher my
apologies
yeah no recorded vote and counsellor fd
thank you
members there will be no recorded vote
there's 20 votes for councillor fd
and three votes for councillor eve um
so the decision is for councillor hefty
thank you
back to councillor angela law sorry
councillor law sorry
angela law germany can the appointment
set out in addendum 2 on pages 14.9 to
1410
he agreed subject to noting the results
of the votes we've just taken
okay again members that
i will do that via the normal uh roll
call of names
i hope that that's all right um are the
appointments set out in addendum 2 on
pages 14.9 to 14 10 agreed subject to
the votes we've just taken
members can you please indicate if you
want a recorded vote whether you're a
for or against a recommendation
or if you wish to abstain right
counsellor mrs
belton no
i'm four thank you myself
no and four councillor butcher
no and four but chairman have we not
voted on the sanctuary rochford we've
got
three seats for four nominations
no we're not there they're not there yet
councilor butcher
okay sorry did i did you give me your
vote
counselor mrs good yes
no i'm four thank you chairman
the answer fd no i'm four
thank you councillor hazelwood
the answer no and four
councillor ionu no and four councillor
lucas gill
macpherson
council macphers macpherson
sorry chairman that thing wouldn't work
um
no and four and i'm going to have to say
good night now
okay thank you councillor merrick no
and four thank you uh councillor milne
no and four councillor mrs rowe
thank you chairman no and four thank you
councillor mrs shaw
thank you mr chairman no and four
councillor mr shaw
no i'm four councillor smith
now recorded vote and four thank you
accounts are sparing
no and four council no
and four council web
no and for council western
very cool devoting for chairman council
wilkinson
councilor williams no and approved thank
you chairman
still wilson
no sorry no and abstain
council wooden no and for
thank you
members the vote is 22 votes for
none against two abstentions so that has
been
agreed thank you members over to angela
law
chairman recommendation three relates to
the attendance by the leader of the
council and
portfolio holders as the council
representatives at a number of external
partnerships
as detailed in paragraph 3.4 the report
and this is to be noted by the council
chairman
thank you members again i shall go
through
the uh roll call um
you can vote
noting it's simply noting members that's
it please
counselor mrs belton
noted councillor mrs butcher noted
myself councillor dre noted councillor
fd
united councillor gooding noted
now sir hazelwood
councilman milne noted
that mrs rowe thank you chairman noted
thank you councillor mrs shaw noted
councillor mr shaw noted the answer
smith
noted now suspend noted
council ward noted councillor mrs weston
noted chairman councillor wilkinson
yeah noted chairman council williams no
two thank you chairman
councillor wilson
noted thank you council wootton noticed
it
remember that has been noted thank you
very much
i shall pass you back to angela
i'm still muted chairman recommendation
4 relates to the appointment to
three seats on the sanctuary in uh on
sanctuary in russia
in rochester committee for the 29th
2020-2021 municipal year we have
received four nominations from
councillor mrs lumley councilman mill
councillor mrs shaw and councillor mrs
mason
sets out an addendum 3 on page 14.11
which will be determined by voting
chairman could members please
indicate whether uh out of the four
nominations who they wish to not uh vote
for
that is councillor mrs lumley councillor
mr uh councilman milne council mrs shaw
or councillor mrs mason okay and they're
voting for three of those three out of
the four
yeah members again on the roll call
you're voting for three
out of the four okay councillor
mrs belton
no councillors lovely meal and shaw
myself no to recorded vote councillors
lumley milne
and mrs shaw uh councillor fd
yes to record evo lumley milne and shaw
councillor mrs gooding no to recorded
vote and for councillors lovely
at milne and shaw thank you councillors
councillor hazelwood
family shawn no councillor hudson
no recorded vote and councillors lumley
mill and mrs shaw
councillor merrick no
and councillors mrs lumley milne and
mrs shaw councillor milner
no to recording vote and uh councillors
lonely
milner and shaw councillor mrs rowe
thank you chairman no and counselor mrs
jude lumley
councillor milne and councillor mrs shaw
thank you
councillor mrs shaw no for recording
vote
uh councillor mrs june lumley mr milne
and mrs laurene shaw
thank you councillor mr shaw no to a
recorded vote
councillors mrs lumley mr milne and mrs
shaw
thank you councillor smith no to a
recorded vote councillors lonely mel
mr
you're muted dave counter sparring
i'll come back to your council sparing
um
council ward yeah it's no to a recorded
vote and it's yes
to councillors lumley milne and
shaw
councillor webb thank you chairman no to
a recorded vote
and councillors alumni milne and
councillor mrs
shaw please counselor wilkinson
no to record advice enough staying
chairman thank you councillor
williams thank you chairman no to a
recorded vote councillors mrs lumley mrs
shaw
and councillor mueller councillor wilson
a no to recorded vote and councillor
mason
thank you councillor wootton
no to a recorded vote councillors mrs
lumley
councillor milner and councillor mrs
shaw thank you
council sparing i'll come back to you
can hear me
can you hear me now yes you can yeah the
system's going
uh no to record it counts as lovely meal
and sure
thank you chairman sorry i didn't hear
if you said
me counselor western
council mrs lamley council mr meal and
council mrs
shaw thank you thank you
and chairman you didn't call me either
what's your vote in councillor butcher
yes it's not a recorded vote and it's
councillors lumley
milne and shaw thank you thank you
right there are 20
votes each for councillors lumley
milne and mrs shaw there's one vote for
councillor
uh mason and two abstentions so the
council's going forward our councillors
lumley milne and mrs shaw thank you
members back to angela law
do you need to get the appointments
agreed
chairman recommendation five relates to
the appointment to the essex
police fire and crime panel the
nominations are set out in addendum 4 on
page 14.12 to be agreed by the council
thank you
members um the appointments of the essex
police fire and
crime panel said on page 15.11
are agreed members again to indicate
your wish
for recorded vote or whether you wish
for or against the recommendation
or you wish to abstain i shall do a roll
call
can i suggest we do six as well
yes chairman also recommendation six
relates to the appointment to the essex
county wide
traveler unit the nominations are set
out in addendum 5
on page 14. 13 to
also to be agreed chairman members
i should take our recommendation five
and six together
i've just read out recommendation five
recommendation six
is the appointments to the essex
countrywide travel unit set out in
addendum 5 on page 14.13
are agreed can you please indicate
members when i call your name as to
whether you wish to recorded vote
or for or against those recommendations
thank you councilman mrs butcher
no and for myself no
and for councillor fd
thank you councillor mrs gooding now and
four thank you chairman
thank you council hazelwood
council hazelwood
no an abstain thank you councillor
hawkway
councillor lucas skill no and four
councillor merrick no and four
councillor milne no and four
councillor merrick certified
thank you chairman now and for
councillor mrs shaw
thank you mr chairman known for
counseling mr shaw
known for mrs smith no i'm for
now says sparing now and for councillor
wald
oh and fortune councillor mrs weston
known for chairman councillor wilkinson
known for chairman councillor webb
no and four thank you chairman nelson
wilkinson
sorry councillor williams my apologies
uh thank you chairman no
and for councillor wilson no
and abstain counsellor woodson
no i'm for chairman thank you
members there are 21 votes four
and two against sorry two abstentions my
apologies 21 for
and two abstentions so those uh
recommendations
five and six are carried thank you and
agreed
i should go back to angelo thank you
chairman chairman recommendation seven
relates to the
nominations to four seats on the local
highway panel
and these are set out in addendum six on
page 14.14 to be agreed by council
we have received seven nominations from
council
councillor hazelwood councilman mrs rowe
councillor
mr shaw councillor ward councillor yves
and councillorani in newport which will
need to be determined
chairman to be uh to clarify we will
need four names out of the seven on
page 14.4 okay
i hope that is clear members four names
of the seven
and the four the seven again a council
of hazelwood councillors mrs rowe
councillor shaw councillors ward
councillor eaves councillor ionu and
councillor
newport
councillor belton
no councillors hazelwood rowe mr shaw
and wald
myself no to a recorded vote uh
councillors hazelwood mrs rowe council
shaw and council award thank you
councillor efti now to record vote
hazelwood row shaw
no to recorded vote and for
councillors hazelwood
row shaw and council award
thank you thank you councillor butcher
notebook recorded vote and councillors
hazelwood rowe mr shaw and councillor
ward
thank you uh councillor hookway
come back to your council councilor
gooding
hazenwood
uh hate wood shaw uh robin ward
thank you councillor hawkway can you
hear me
i'll come back to you councillor hudson
no to a recorded vote
the councillors hazelwood mrs rowe
shaw and ward thank you councillor ionu
uh roe ward eaves
and yuanu thank you mr lucas gill
no to a recorded vote and councillors
hazelwood
mrs rowe shaw and ward
thank you councillor merrick
no hazelwood mrs rowe
mr shaw and ward councillor milner
no to the recorded vote and council says
hazelwood
mrs rowe mr shaw and council award
councillor mrs rowe thank you chairman
now and councillors hazelwood roe ward
and mr shaw councillor mrs shaw
thank you chair uh no to a recorded vote
and uh councillors uh hazelwood mrs rowe
mr p shaw and mr wald
thank you mr shaw councillor mr shaw
no for recorded vote councils hazelwood
rowe shaw and ward thank you
councillor smith no recorded vote
councillors hayes and woodrow mr short
and ward
the answer sparing no counselors
hazelwood rose shaw ward
councillor wald that's a no and it's
hazelwood
mrs rowe uh mr shaw and ward
councillor webb no and councillors
hazelwood
row shaw and ward please counsel
western very courteous
chairman council wilkinson
no recorded votes counsellor newport
councillor eve's councillor yuanu
and without any hesitation because she's
amazing in this role as councillor mrs
rowe
your councilor williams thank you
chairman
no to recorded vote and councillor mrs
rowe
councillors hazelwood shaw and ward
thank you councillor wilson go to
recorded vote and councillors eve
yanu and council newport
okay council woodson no to a recorded
vote
councillor hazelwood this is rowe
shaw ward have i missed anybody else
now
can you hear me now if you'd like to
cast your vote
i believe he's now left chairman oh is
he
okay thank you councilwood
so 20 24
record
those are the ones that are elected
those are the numbers for those and then
there's one extension
now members the votes are as follows
there's 20 votes for council ward
kept 20 votes for councillor shaw 21 for
councillor rowe
and 20 for councillor hazelwood
two for cows to newport three for
councillor eves
and three for councillor ionu and one
abstention so i can confirm that the
members going forward of the local
highways panel
are councillors ward shaw rowe
and hazelwood i shall now pass you back
to angela law for recommendation eight
chairman recommendation eight relates to
the appointment of two members and two
substitutes to the river crouch coastal
community team steering group
four nominations have been received for
councillor mrs lumley
the portfolio holder for enterprise
councillor hookway and
councilloryani for the two appointments
as set out in the device addendum
7 on page 14.16
which will need to be determined
okay members um if you can please
indicate um your vote to the river couch
crouch coastal community team steering
group
come in there please you can
chairman notwithstanding what i said
earlier could we receive some
clarification
as to constitutionally whether um
these are up for election my
understanding was it was subject to
terms of reference within the actual
river crouch coastal community team
steering group
and
whether or not
thank you chairman
chairman if it insists i'm able to uh
speak to the point
i'm sorry angela hutchins you wish to
speak
thank you chairman i can i can answer
the question um chairman the matter
was brought in front of council on the
17th of december of last year
and the recommendation of that report
was that the
terms of reference be fulfilled by
putting forward um
mrs councillor mrs june lumley uh as the
named chairperson of the uh river crouch
coastal community team
and she was therefore appointed um by
full council at that point
in her past in her capacity as uh both
councillor of the
uh of the um uh rochefort district
council but also in her own capacity as
a
as an individual and the second um
applicant therefore under that report
was a recommendation for the portfolio
holder for finance
sorry i beg your portfolio holder for
enterprise i'm reading here
um be named as the other representative
on the uh
coastal river crouch coastal community
team steering group
because the aims and objectives of that
syrian group fall within the remit of
the enterprise portfolio
so um the recommendation um
for the in the report of council in uh
december of last year was that it should
be for mrs lomley
and for the count the portfolio holder
for enterprise
thank you angela for that clarification
okay
members just to clarify we're voting two
out of the four
the four being councillors mrs lumley
the portfolio holder for enterprise
councillor hookway and councillor ionu
yeah can i can i just ask if if we've
already agreed
the structure in to full council
can we are we permitted to overrule that
i don't know i'm just asking the
question if that was agreed
as part of the the structure of the
transfer
to the district to rochford from malden
i believe it was
you know if that was agreed by full
council
that structure can we do we overrule
that
angela hutchins can you respond to that
question of counselor sparing
i can indeed chair uh the um
the appointments were made in december
as i've said they can of course be
changed
but the appointments were for mrs lumley
and for the portfolio holder
for enterprise so the portfolio holder
for enterprise is a post rather than a
named
individual and similarly the substitute
for the um portfolio holder for
enterprise which is the portfolio holder
for environment
so the recommendation needs to be
amended to that regard
thank you chairman to make life easier
because i i
was part of the uh
the me a meeting at the steering group i
would
actually drop out of the nominations to
uh allow lumley and and the enterprise
going forward
three now so members just to be clear
we're voting two out of the three
and a three being councillor mrs lumley
the portfolio holder for enterprise
and councillor hookway can you indicate
please when i call your name
the two out of the three you wish to
vote for
councillor mrs belton no recorded
council alumni and council orton
councillor mrs butcher
no recorded councillor mrs lumley
and counts for enterprise
thank you uh myself council alumnly and
the portfolio holder for
enterprise councillor fd uh
council alumni and a portfolio for
enterprise and no recording vote
thank you councillor mrs gooding no
recorded vote
uh councillor lumley and uh the
portfolio holder for
enterprise council hazelwood
no recording vote alumni portfolio
holder for enterprise
councillor io no recorder uh vote
council alumnly
and the portfolio for enterprise
councillor lucas gill
no recorded vote councillor mrs glumly
and the portfolio
holder for enterprise council merrick
recorded votes what's the mrs romney and
portfolio holder for enterprise
uh councillor milne no recording
vote council alumnae and the portfolio
for enterprise
um thank you councillor mrs rowe
thank you chairman councillor lumley and
portfolio holder for enterprise and no
to recorded vote
thank you councillor mrs shaw no to the
recorded vote
uh my vote goes for uh mrs j lumley and
portfolio for enterprise counsellor mr
shaw
no recorded vote uh mrs lamley and
portfolio older french prize councillor
smith
no recorded votes councillor lonely and
portfolio holder for enterprise
council sparing no recorded vote
council alumni portfolio hold a french
prize
council award no recorded vote
uh for mrs lumley and the portfolio
holder for enterprise chairman
thank you councillor webb very recorded
vote uh council alumni and their
portfolio holder for enterprise
council western no recording vote
chairman uh council mrs lumley and
portfolio holder for enterprise thank
you
councillor uh wilkinson no recorded vote
chairman
um councillor mrs lumley and the
portfolio holder french prize i would
just add
chairman um i don't know what your
intentions are but i don't think we can
actually
uh vote to accept recommendation eight
because i think didn't angela hutchins
say that the
one of the substitutes needs to be the
portfolio holder for
community rent or environment so it
appears to be completely incorrect
at the moment i don't know if you want
to amend that for four weeks i think she
misspoke
oh did she be spoke yes i did she
corrected herself yeah additional fair
enough
sorry chairman i'm here to put you off
your train of thoughts
angela hutchins can you clarify that
point chairman yes it is the uh
portfolio holder for environment who's
the substitute
is correct apologies to councillor
wilkinson so we can continue
okay council williams
thank you chairman um
councillor mrs lumley and portfolio
holder for enterprise thank you
councillor wilson
um no to record his vote the portfolio
home french prize and council hawkway
councillor woodson no recorded vote
councillor mrs lumley
and the board media
thank you members i'll come
members there are 22 votes for
councillor lumley 23 votes for the
portfolio
holder for enterprise and one for
councillor
hookway so it's council lumley and the
portfolio
holder for enterprise to go forward
thank you members that completes item
14 members i said that earlier
uh we still have item agenda item 12 and
agenda item
13 to go through
the time is now three minutes past 11
items 12 and 13 should be relatively
quick
so with your agreement members i shall
quickly go through items
12 and 13. great
item uh gender items
counselor mrs shaw i was gonna say if
they are quick
can we do them if not can we please do
them next week because it got
going this meeting going past 11 o'clock
he's i now think's unacceptable
um thank you
counselor ionu
thank you chair with regards to the
substitutes for the
river kraut coastal community team i
appreciate that uh
from uh uh the officer angela hutchinson
that uh
the end uh and sorry portfolio for
environment will be a substitute
who's going to be the do we need to vote
for
hazel or mrs shaw for the other
substitute
there are only two nominations for the
substitutes which are fine
there's no need for a vote
okay um members i will take
another vote on whether to extend oh no
please don't oh i've already got two
votes
thank you chairman i was just going to
say items 12 and 13 are relatively quick
and i hear what other counselors are
saying but we do have a lot of business
to get through
on the 14th so please let's just go with
it guys
thank you i agree let's carry on agenda
item 12
scheme of delegation um
members do you agree the scheme of
delegation is set out in part
three a and c of the constitution
subject to the amendments agreed in the
previous
item which was item 11. again
i should do a roll call of names please
recall
please let me know if you want a
recorded vote or for
an event councillor mrs belton
no recorded vote for councillor mrs
butcher
no recorded vote and for myself
no recorded vote and four councillor fd
no record he voted for councillor mrs
budding
mrs gooding i'll come back to you
council hazelwood
no recorded vote and four
councillor hudson no recorded vote and
four
council no recorded vote and four
council lucas gill no and four
uh counselor merrick
both council emil no recorded vote
and four councillor mrs rowe
thank you chairman no and for councillor
mrs shaw
known for councillor mr shaw
known for councillor smith
no recorded vote for council sparing
no for council ward
oh fortune council western
no recording voting for chairman
council wilson
councillor wilson
community councilor wilson
no informed thank you councillor woodson
no in four i'll come back to councillor
gooding councillor gooding can you hear
me
yes no i'm four thank you chairman thank
you
that members has been agreed item 13
council members um this is just for
noting
can you approach scheduling of council
meetings
on the 14th of july 2020
20th of october 2020
15th of december 2020 16th of february
2021
23rd of february 2021 and 20th of april
2021 again normal
roll call members 19
19
that one for you sir i'll take that as
noted their members
can i thank you all for your patience
sorry can i just come in i've just had a
text from councillor burton
uh unfortunately his mum has been taken
ill so he sent his apologies can we
please know those
we will yes
thank you very much chairman for yours
thank you thank you very much
thank you very much